you
hello and welcome from the swedish
academy well we've just discovered who's
been awarded the 2009 nobel prize in
literature with me to discuss this
year's prize is pierre de england
permanent secretary of the swedish
academy thank you very much for joining
us could we begin by you telling us who
has been awarded the 2009 nobel prize in
literature and why please it has been
given to a German author born in Romania
but now living in German and her name is
her family and why she received the
prize simply because Susan excellent
orphan excellent or that with a truly
fantastic language on the one hand and
on the other having a capacity of really
giving you a sense not only of what
about what it was like living in a
dictatorship but also what is like being
part of a minority in other country what
it's like to be in exile she's talking
about really big issues like that so her
work is really is noted for depicting
the hardships of life under the
Ceausescu regime regime in Romania how
has a life shape to work it has shaped
her work in many ways one of the ways is
her extreme precision with words she has
been living in a dictatorship that are
constantly misusing abusing the language
and this has forced a sort of our
skepticism in her regarding the use of
words regarding the use of languages or
she has a very very fine-tuned precision
and I think in her language and I think
it comes out of this experience living
in a in a in a dictatorship that
corrupts language in its everyday use
and also living as a in a minority
language so I think that that gives her
this uniqueness is double experience
that being a part of a language minority
but also being a living in a in a
pressed society and how is that
precision of prose and that experience
or the manifest itself throughout her
work
what as I said in this in this position
she has not these long winding sentences
she's very very they are short they are
very picturesque full of images and so
on and she sort of weeds big scenes he's
not a epic writer she doesn't try big
thick epic things she often has no
really narrative strand at all it's more
episodes or anecdotes or fragments and
so on that are slowly building up this
big picture and so for the uninitiated
reader where should one begin Oh perhaps
with what many considered her best novel
it's called in German head steer I don't
know if it's translated into English you
could translate it into the hot animal
and it's about a group of friends who
has managed to leave romania living in
exile but it's also about how this
experience about living under this
oppression and eventually leaving how it
splits them asunder how they turn
against each other it's it's a it's a
very it's a very dark book and so where
do you think we'll of fits within the
literary history of writers who've
conveyed the hardships of life under
repressive regimes I think she fits in
very well her latest novel Artem Chaika
would you could translate into the swing
of breathing or something like that it
for the first time she's writing about
something that is not in her own
experience and that is about she had a
mother spending five years in a Soviet
labour camp and it's built on
experiences of people in her village her
mother and mostly on a boat she got to
learn in Germany and this book I think
it goes in fits in very well in a
succession of grand books about the
shall we call it the camp experience
shalimar primally area etc and you
mentioned her a recent work I mean is
her recent work or any recent
circumstances providing the
pelling reason for awarding of the prize
this year I think she could have very
well received a prize without her latest
work without Adam sure I could but but
as I said I think it's an absolutely
breathtaking book and this is your first
announcement as Secretary Academy won
the toss of course is interpreting the
conditions in alfred nobel's will now
how are you interpreting that the rather
and precise wording of awarding
outstanding achievement in an ideal
direction well I think she fits very
well there always been a bit of leeway
in regards to the Testament than those
words but I I think she fits very very
well because this is a person and you
can see that in her literature there is
a enormous moral momentum in what she
writes so I think she fits perfectly and
one question have you managed to speak
to her yet yes I got in contact with her
well in time and I've spoken with her
and she was very very happy and she has
agreed to come to Stockholm to receive
the price well that the announcement was
greeted with an enormous round of
applause so it's clearly a popular
decision thank you very much thank you
that's for more information about the
literature prize please visit
nobelprize.org where you can find
background material and will soon be
able to see an exclusive interview with
the new nivelle Nora to literature
that's about it for this live webcast
but join us tomorrow well we we will
discover who will be awarded the 2009
nobel peace prize the announcement
scheduled for eleven o'clock central
european time but for now it's goodbye
from all of us at Nobel Prize org
you